it occurs to me that red shirt red
bagger is probably red overload however
I'm the one who had to watch this movie
so of the two of us
you're good the house so the house stars
Will Ferrell Annie Poehler and their
friend Jason sudakis hold on Jason
Mantzoukas up that's right cuz it's
funny zone in the moon basically Will
Ferrell Amy Poehler's daughter gets
accepted to college they can't pay for
the college so they're friends like hey
how about we open up an underground
casino highly illegal Neil but I can pay
off my house you can pay for your kids
college everyone wins
and then they open this underground
casino and money hopefully hopefully
some last two well there are some laughs
in the movie I know there were a couple
of parts that maybe talked a couple of
one-liners that maybe juggles mostly
from that dude more often than not there
were some awkward asked moments it was
like that's supposed to be funny take a
beat for the audience to laugh continue
next a bummer this movie is it's an
interesting premise to trim the red band
trailer it made me laugh and when you
watch the executioner like knob which is
kind of awkward not a lot of laughs so
funniest part in the movie is actually
in the red band trailer I'll save you
some time I'll link the red band trailer
below go to this time right there in the
trailer then you'll see the funniest
part of the movie it was as funny in the
movie as it was in the trailer but now
that you saw it the trailer don't have
to watch the movie you're welcome the
last act of the movie tries to build on
this little subplot that's happening but
it just came across as floppy a [ __ ] it
came across like they were like alright
we finished production of the movie
alright it's about an hour long we need
more time we need filler what to do
right creates a subplot and have that
payoff in the end will pay off for the
movie not pay off for the audience this
is the M for the audience you're just
looking at like yep it just feels choppy
out of place boring just downright messy
like there are some jokes in some
moments in the movie that it's like they
were constructed as afterthought salsa I
just about oh let's watch The Walking
Dead together and then the next thing
they're watching The Walking Dead
they're being awkward with the daughter
and then the scenes over but we could
have done without that but again it's
like they were like we need different
all the time so we'll just put awkward s
jokes in the movie they don't really pay
off I'd love to say Will Ferrell shines
in his movie or some like that when he
really doesn't Amy Poehler was funnier
than Will Ferrell Jason
and zookas really stole the show if you
think it's gonna be the shortest review
ever there's not much to say about the
movie but I'm not going to do to you
what the movie did to me which is just
make [ __ ] up and throw [ __ ] at you
because I need to fill time know what
you need to know the movie has a couple
of funny parts a couple of funny lines
but in the end the movie just generally
speaking falls flat it's sloppy it's
messy and with the movie wraps up you
walk out you're like okay now we're
dealing with a 22 hour day that's my
full day the fact that I can't think of
more to say really shows you you're not
going to remember this movie in t-minus
10 minutes ya already forgot alright
guys so the house have you seen it what
did you think about it probably not
going to because I said you shouldn't
I'm just saying you're probably not
going through so what is a disappointing
comedy this year for you whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]